india's first vaccine was given to a
sanitation worker
relief and jubilation but it has come at
a cost
the virus has claimed the lives of more
than 152
000 people so far and with over 10.5
million cases
the country is only second to the united
states
prime minister modi launched one of the
largest vaccine programs in the world
in the first phase india will vaccinate
30 million people
in the second phase this number will
reach 300 million
the elderly those with health problems
will get the vaccine in the next phase
dr suresh kumar the medical
superintendent heads the largest coveted
19 hospital in delhi
how will you describe today today is the
festival
for us we are like a
soccer vodka winner and everybody is
excited
it's been a tragic winter for the sharma
household
65 year old devi ram sharma died within
four days of being admitted to a
hospital
i hope and i pray that this virus is
removed
through the use of vaccination and
others don't have to suffer
what our family need had gone through it
was a very difficult time
at delhi's nightcart the largest hindu
crematorium
avanish is donning a pp suit to perform
the last rights
restrictions in place families have no
time for mourning
as farewells are hurried and from afar
traditional last rites are rushed under
the overbearing shadow
of the virus the bereavement a mere
formality
never lazarus sky news delhi